the town of lytton near the west coast
in british columbia
endured temperatures close to 50 degrees
on tuesday
the day before more than a thousand
residents from the area were forced to
flee their homes because of the flames
gordon murray was one of those who had
to evacuate and captured this
extraordinary footage and gordon joins
me now
gordon thank you for being with us you
have
captured scenes of absolute devastation
just describe for us what it was like
well thanks for having me it was uh a
puck
apocalyptic is really the only words i
can use to describe it
without exaggeration as you can see from
the footage there were fires
on both sides of the road uh and their
buildings just bursting into flames
trees exploding you could hear them
uh it was and we had no really no
idea how bad it was and uh because there
was no warnings
from uh from anyone of what was
happening we just had
we basically had to figure out what was
going on
and uh when the cell service died we had
been trying to figure out you know
trying to check
uh cell and uh internet to find out what
what the situation was and there was no
information so
when the cell service died we realized
we just had to get out of there so
we grabbed our pets and just started
driving we had no we didn't even know
which way to head
because there was smoke and fire
everywhere and fortunately
we made it through and and where are you
and how are you now gordon
uh we're now i mean we're in shock
obviously it was
it's hard to believe there was only like
36 hours ago it seems like 36 days
um but we're staying with family in
vancouver
so we're relatively uh you know that
that's
a long way away from where we were um
but it's it's it's difficult we've we've
just discovered
basically last night because we when we
left our house was still intact but we
discovered that the
there's been some aerial photos
published in our house and 95
if not 99 of the other houses have been
completely
wiped off the map the town doesn't exist
anymore
oh i'm i'm so sorry to hear that
uh gordon what was going through
your mind as you were driving through
those flames given that the speed
that this had engulfed the the community
catching residents by surprise and
you're driving trying to get out of it
well yeah i was just complete shocked
because we had no idea
that it was this bad as i said we were
on the edge of the boat we were
on the uh the edge of the village away
from where the fire started so we didn't
realize how bad it was until we
started driving through it um but i just
want to
point out that this is really you know
it's a litten story but it goes far
beyond that because that that day before
four other communities in bc exceeded
the all-time canadian uh
heat record so this is a climate change
story it's just there's no doubt about
it there's
the the uh you know we
we were not prepared for it and uh
you know london is at about the same
latitude as litton
so this is coming for for everybody even
in temperate
countries don't uh we we need to uh
start we're long past starting we've
been we should have started a long time
ago but we need to tackle climate change
in a very very serious way
we need to decarbonize our economy uh
because this is going to be coming for
all
everyone very soon that that's that's
the story here is that
nobody thought it was going to happen
nobody knew it was going to happen and
with 15 minutes
15 minutes the entire town was on fire
um gordon we are so very sorry uh for
you thank you
for talking to us our thoughts are with
you and the very best of luck for the
weeks and months ahead